[Music]
hello everybody I'm tending my topics
I'm Tilly work for Ericsson branding
attorney my topic today is a spot on an
icy Street Fighter how many people here
live spot a lot how many people live
football
Wow along so so lucky for you because
today I went talk something about the
football and I think we use a IOT data
we know that a lot of issue to analyze
this about the football for example we
analyzing math like analyzes a match the
player is a fan but in my topic today I
will give you the space okay about Rita
met checking so how we do return metric
one of my presentation included three
parts the first part is a I will show
you how we clattering the data and the
second part I will show you how to data
and I see squid Python and in the last
night I queen soyu's the demo data and
Isaac with tableau and you can see
clearly about the data so how we can
gather in the data one of the way that
FIFA user to track the position of
player or some information like energy
or heart rate they put a lot of sensor
for example in the body of player to
know the heart rate of the energy under
the zoo behind the shock and inside the
ball to know the position of ball player
and then the sense of win Center data
put the epicenter not aesthetic
collector data and then we use a lot of
application to analyze this data but in
the in our topic today I will show you
how we analyze it this data with
patterns
so for example we got the data of the
first part of him with how the people of
the team so what we can do support time
I think you need to try open the data
import some nigel-murray and use a panda
to open the file and here we have an
information the 450 row of data we have
a separate column and a lot of row but
we don't know exactly the site data so
we can use a data frame shape and we
know the site data wow it's very big
data there are total Arau let's an
600,000 row and for column the name of
column it turns I am dividing X naught
and y / it look very similar and how
many divides a user to check the
position of player we can use a data
frame column v vy ID unique and we know
the naam the name of divide the user to
check the position of player and we sum
the total of Viva here we have 11 the
divide so we if we want to know how many
record win win receive from acne by we
can use a divide value cow and we have
other divides
we've also number record more than
55,000 record
so now we want to know the details the
information inside the data we can use a
data frame node info to know the thing
inside and we know all the times time is
Phi is a plot the device ID
ty in export and why pots is throat and
total data is no noon and we do similar
for acne by if you want to see clearly
and we have a the same the same type
without but you see so we cut queries
from it
Levi is smaller than a total the record
from ik device we have a total of the
data and here we try to do some space or
ting lies a min mock-up position a big
player it played eight players the Queen
put one divine side so we know the
minimum maximum of export and why part
of active I and we we can do similar
with not afraid no describer but here we
give more information about the data
like you can know the causal means the
standard the mean of the max and the
percent tip of data do similar with
total data so some people ask me when
the game began so we can use though we
know that the start game this mean the
time the first time we got from sensor
so we try to cone minute pants time and
Mac stamps time we know that time as
total and this segi but the instant the
result myself mini seconds so it's very
hard to know a weekday so we can use the
dysfunction to convert to the format
here man
and we have a resell the grain start in
23 month 2009 at 6:30 p.m. and stop the
same day at 7:15 p.m.
so now how long absurd game we use we
Texas time my start time and we know
this game is 45 minute and we see there
is an actual time in that game and now
we try to processing the data before
processing the data we need to summarize
what we have in the original data we
have a time time we have a DVID we have
export and wipe out and now what can we
do with this data it is the things that
I said therefore you can do with this
data we can calculate the return the
distance the total distance the velocity
the
run so turning boy but in this books up
I win focus and help you step by step to
calculate return piston and total
distance so calculate the returns it
means you separates the Napa and put it
in minute and time and second Fozzie and
we can use this function to do it take
the time the sense of record my first
part time and divide for 1000 because
here is a mini second and divide for 60
so we know the minute that one because
we can commit the game from minute one
and then we have a one more column max
per minute and total the record in
minute one win so one minute 45 in Seoul
for a PI and we do seem in a week second
and but we take the remain of the
different time for spam with city and
plot one because the game start the
second second one and we have a one more
column is there any way fatter than tea
yes we have we can use a deep move and
we can do similar and we have the same
data to column madam and minute so now
how we can calculate the distance of
player we know that the distance of 2 pi
is equal to how the square of Horace no
distance and the vertical distance and
square or abscissa
addition and we use can try to do it
with Python and apply this function for
device and we can run it for Toto divine
wisest function too long when we then we
take around 30 minute is too long
because it's very big data and how to
improve the performance of this function
I will talk another in another topic and
here is a result we have a one more
column about the discipline of
player and now to calculate the total
distance in order to calculate the total
distance a big player we accumulate the
distant players in the period second
order period data and then we try to
apply it and we have one more column
total distance and now try to summarize
in the data we have now we have more
than more for colum McCann per minute
madam second distant total distance and
we know the minimum maximum of listen
and total distance of the data but now
we want to note detail for each player
we can use a similar which you agree
divided and then which we describe and
we know the information of a player or
active I so now before go to the
visualization we review the information
of data that we have we have a CSV file
45 minute a poem 11 player they no chain
player in this game and we have x time
divine ID for this an export and wipeout
and we just calculate pre a formal
column met time per minute madam second
listen and total distance try to save it
in CSV file and now we try to do it with
tableau and you can see we so live with
top noona
okay here is wow it's very hard for me
to see okay so here we have a we open it
in tableau okay support time try to add
the data the positions that you save the
Napa here I up take five because it is a
CSV file for example here is a data try
to load it
I have already so I don't need up
anymore okay
and when we have a data we open one more
okay so now try to if you want to plot
the information of the footman you try
to find the information for the one
picture above the mm Pete sorry very bad
to say no okay sorry because today no I
didn't see here clearly so I win so you
redirect the reads out here for example
here
back to see okay try to add my crowd
Amit okay we have we need to import a
background image for example here you
need to prepare the picture and to the
column is export and wipe out for the
information and try to fix the position
for example the side of the pit is 0 to
90 to 90 and 0 to 100 but there are some
meter for the goal line and to tonigh so
I have 4 and then you can see due to and
use the 0 0 of the axis equal 0 0 of the
picture and here the 100 0 equals the
the last couple here and then now we try
to do
for example here you two total here is a
hose Napa that we have so it's very hard
to see weeks Napa four-player explain so
we try to take the colorful device ID so
we know a color either each player now
you see a little bit clearly about
information of each player but staying
very hot so we tried to put device ID
for the filter to select each player and
know with so which is the role of player
for example here I to only player one
okay can you get who is that for so is
it gonna keep alright let me solve into
maybe okay
now I to player number two who is that
he is a ride offender right number three
he is a left defender number four he is
a defender
maybe meter number five he defined in
the meter
okay six so you can get who is a maybe
he is a mid fighter
so who is that he is a dry meat fighter
try to do with another player number
nine number a okay he's a mid fighter
number night okay I get that he is a
tackle or strike try to do with player
number ten and player number eleven we
have a he is a striker and player number
eleven okay he is a mid fighter right
let me fire okay and when we samurai
also information up player we can get
with the formation the user in that game
okay here's the user for Mason 4 4 5 5 4
2 for that game and now we try to do
some special information for all the
player or each player we we can go back
tableau and see ok for example now if I
want to see what is the position of own
player in minute 1 second 3 2 second
second one two second three what we can
do with tableau we try to put madam for
me from minute to eat the tube you and
then you have to Train it to distance
okay now I have a teacher need to
dimension it is an attribute okay try to
solve it
Pinto so Pinto so here if I want to see
okay here for example I want to see in
minute one second one two three
Oh second one to seven up all the player
I to all the player here and you see
they move a lot of positioned right so
what they do in five minute
I don't know how much okay here's a fire
I chew here fine okay here is a total
the movement of a player when they move
in five minute and no here is a second
in total in minute here he finding it
okay and total circuit
okay and you see they move a lot of
positions here's a position Toto a
minute
okay in three minute what they do in on
the second here is a position of all the
player in first three minutes and now
for example now I need to know what I do
in fact one player do in 15 the first 15
minute what I can do okay we try to make
for example I need to know player number
four what when he do in first 15 minutes
okay it's very hard to know and I need
to know separate X 50 minutes so I
choose my time per minute for color okay
and now I have a 2d by color - three
path
okay so you see in the first 15 minutes
they move in the position as a red color
and the second 15 minutes I move upon
supposition is a white color and the
last 15 minutes I move as a position as
a blue color and here you see that a big
player but if I divide that's only 15
minute okay
very bad
okay for example for example here in
18-minute we divide three paths so it
part is a six six six minutes so in the
first six minutes I study in the red
position and in the rest position have a
red boy and the size of minutes 7 to 12
they stay in the position with the white
color and in the minute
13 to 18 they stay in the position as a
blue color and we can go for 2-player
and then what they do okay it's hard to
see where which one other player may be
okay so I choose a sunny three minutes
so ik minute we can you can see a color
they move a position okay three minutes
for two players so now we try to do some
information like meta for a player we
samurai how many minutes a joy and we
seize total 45 minute but about this ik
minute why 46th minute here because we
have a sum
in the minute 46 we have a destiny 1-1
record great from the sensor it's normal
when you walk with IOT data because so
that our chance for transfer to the data
center and when the the game stopped you
can still get it and you have to stop
the the connection with essential so you
see the games that's only 45 but here
they so 40 sigma cut in 46 in minute 40
sector we got only one data 1 data from
sensor this mean here is allow 50
milliseconds so now we need some
information you can do is calculate some
maximum listed and we know the maximum
distance a big player for example here
in 15 minute or how many 15 minutes so
who got a Mac piston here oh you can do
again as the same week the whole game
the whole up the first game so you can
see the player number two what the
maximum distance how we can do with Toto
distance
here is a total distance up all the
player of the game and we know we can
can we can know who is run faster than
long toggles and as here is a player
number one he is a goalkeeper I give you
the information like that because you
know that's us here is only test data if
you want to know the right a time maybe
you have to pay for it and we can here
we know the total distance of each
player and now we we want to know how
long they run it fitting how fast they
run in 15 minute or X in X period we can
use a the net time we divide three paths
for example here from 1 to fortify so we
in the first 15 minutes they run so the
total distance they run from a prison in
the red and the second 15 minutes they
run the file as a yellow and the blue
one is the last fitting minute one
player run so now if you want to know
with the position the player or the
player can God's the distant Fagor for
example Here I am checking the water
position who is a fogger than 0-3 I put
it the red color and you know the red
color is being that's I got the distant
fatter than the 0.3 meter this means at
the position here the velocity very high
and how to calculate the velocity we can
do in another walk so that is the thing
that I want to show you to do analyze
this with Titan
I samurai you picture about and you can
understand okay so in this topic we know
so step by step to calculate the returns
total distance the distance and about
the velocity is the wrong turning point
and with the energy surpassed up all the
combination between player the dashpot
for the football see you on networks on
thank you for the attention any question
for me okay thanks presentation
just one question have you tried to do
something with the data for example to
derive some kind of player indices
performance estimates who will score
okay it's a very good question but in
this guy you see in the R is no data
what we have are in the or is no data
without to have all the information
about sometimes times only varieties
expert and Waipa and we don't have
enough information to know the score
or the past pone so if you want to do
this index you have to get put more
information up as a device for example
iron has another defi of information
open added if I have to compile with
this not set and can make for you more
information and you can know with times
iPads a bone with time that keeps a bone
and with terms which they have Oaks call
any other question is that that are
public available or to make it publicly
publicly available for them thank you
for the question
actually this data who are public in the
internet but they do like me ran we do
random because if you want to know the
exactly the information for example a
boxer una arraignment it might be you
have to fight because you know they have
to buy a lot of Levi's a lot of sense so
to put in the player and record it to
know the performing a player or to check
the game and they have to serve it so if
you want to do maybe you have to play a
game Isis only so you the way they do
but exactly needs a data
I don't hammer and if I have a saw sorry
I can't public yeah thank you for a
presentation and I would like to invite
you for ignite talks to track number one
to room number one thank you thank you
so much
you